- I couldn't help but notice,
first of all, I'm such a fan.
So excited.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- But I also noticed you have like a,
is this special, this necklace
thing that's going on?
- This is me and my late
daughter, Bobbi Kristina.
- Oh! And then there are these little,
is it quartz around it or what?
Is there--
- Yeah, little beads
that her sister gave me.
- Oh!
- Our daughter, Hendrix.
- Our daughter, Hendricks,
made it for me to go on tour with.
- Oh my gosh, I love that!
I didn't even notice there
was the picture on that.
I was talking about the
beads and so I was just like,
oh, are you into like stones and stuff?
I am quartz nerd.
That's so beautiful.
- Thank you.
- And you carry that around,
that's such a beautiful thing.
Y'all look so nice.
- Thank you.
- Like ready for a photo
shoot (indistinct).
I was like.
So we're celebrating Rad Momma's Week.
I'm sure that she is an awesome mama,
two take kiddos.
- Oh yes! Yes.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Totally. Totally.
- Is it fun? Is it a crazy house?
- It's not a crazy house.
It's a very loving house.
- Mine's crazy.
- It's not crazy to him.
It's definitely crazy to me.
- I was gonna say it's crazy
to me. It's loving and crazy.
- Yes, absolutely.
- It's crazy to her, but not to me.
(Alicia chuckling)
(audience laughing)
- Yes.
- So what's your favorite
part of being a mama?
- Oh, man!
Just watching these little
humans become their personalities
and them big selves.
And then it just takes you
back to when you were a child
and all the things you loved
and watching it through their eyes.
- You like re-experience it.
- You re-experience it!
That is the gift of being
a mother, absolutely.
- Yeah. I agree.
- It's a beautiful thing.
- I agree.
- Yeah.
- So wait, is it true that,
you know, when you were young,
you heard music in your head all the time?
Is that true?
- Yeah.
I used to bang my head against the--
- So I used to like write all the time,
but you just heard stuff constantly.
- I just heard music constantly.
And I would bang my head
and didn't know why I would
bang my head against the wall
all the time.
And the teachers used to tell my mother,
you know, he's banging
his head again and--
- Yeah,
that would kinda scare me.
- Later on we found out
it was just music.
- Yeah.
For some reason, like why I got into music
was I had a hard time communicating
and it helped me like process it.
My mom was like, maybe
you should write it down.
'Cause I would bottle up.
And I think the music
and everything that I
would hear in my head
and all these thoughts, I
had a hard time getting out,
and music was helpful for me in that area.
Was that like that for you?
- Yes. Lots of talent shows.
I did lots of talent shows
everywhere in Boston.
And I think that's what got me to realize
that this was music.
- Yeah. And that expression feels so good.
Yeah. That it's not only
up here. It's out here.
- Yeah.
- We thank you for it.
We enjoy it out here so.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- So is it true?
I heard that you were
the one that talked him
like out of his like jitters
when you and Whitney were getting married.
- Yes.
- Is that true?
- Yes. Yes.
- Yes, she was the one.
- How full circle is that?
- I know.
- So wait, so you were,
everyone is nervous, right?
Like when you're about
to put the ring.
- That's what I say,
everyone is nervous.
- And if they're not, you're weird.
- I was extra nervous.
- It's a terrifying kinda thing,
that you're like, it's a, you know,
big step.
- It's a big deal.
It's a big step in your life. Yeah.
- I Just love that you
were like, you got this!
- Yeah. I was like, get out!
- And then
y'all end up married like years later.
- Isn't that crazy? I know.
- I know.
- I know. It's amazing.
It's the timing of everything
and why things are meant to be.
But for sure, I was there. I was a friend.
And by then all of his groomsmen
and his brother could not
get him out the bathroom.
So I was like, listen, we are
getting this show on the road.
You know we're here and this
is happening and you know--
- Oh, they couldn't get
you out of the room?
Like you had serious chills.
- I had real, that's what
I was telling you, Kelly.
- Okay. My God, I thought
you meant just like,
you know, everybody's
like me and I'm not--
- No, I locked myself in a bathroom!
- Oh my God!
Okay. Okay.
- Yes.
- [Alicia] So it was fun for us.
- I wasn't gonna come out for anybody.
- Did she know about this?
- I think everybody knew
about it (chuckles).
- Oh my gosh, that's terrifying!
So you're the one that ended up--
- She was like, he better
get out that bathroom!
- He better get out of that bathroom.
- But for some reason,
yeah, I came to the door,
I knocked on it, and I was
talking to him through the door.
And then finally, he like
peeked it a little bit
and I got in, you know?
- Yeah.
- And it was like, let me in, let me in.
Everything's gonna be okay.
And for some reason, he listens to me.
(Alicia and Bobby laughing)
And he eventually came out the bathroom
and went down that aisle. Yeah.
But it is ironic
that it was us again
meeting in life later on
and he would be my husband.
- Yeah. That's so great! I love that!
(audience clapping)
It's like a really interesting,
cool romantic comedy.
- Yeah (laughs).
- I would watch that movie.
(Alicia laughing)
If you were in it.
That was a look at their
show, "Biography: Bobby Brown".
And you're both really honest
about Bobby's struggles
during the documentary.
I think that's really important.
I don't think that you
should do that kinda thing
unless you are honest,
but it's got to be really hard
'cause we're already
under so much scrutiny
in the public eye as it is.
- Yeah.
- So was that really hard
or was it also therapeutic?
- It was definitely therapeutic for me,
having to relive all of the ups and downs.
I think for me,
I needed to clean out all of the cobwebs
in order to move forward in life.
And move forward with my family, my wife,
and to move forward just for my wellbeing.
It was definitely a need.
- I think that's what, people
that are like not for therapy,
you know, they're like, ugh,
I don't believe in therapy.
I'm like, it's just a healthy process
with someone who's outside of
your circle. Won't judge you.
It's one of those things for me.
And I feel like that's the same way,
sometimes almost in an interview,
I feel that way, 'cause I'm very open
and it's a way to kind of express
something that's going on.
And I love that.
I think it helps you kind
of work through stuff.
I think it's a very healthy
way of dealing with things.
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- But so what's the biggest thing
that people, you feel like
get wrong about Bobby's life?
- That he's a big, old meany or something.
He's like the biggest--
- Wait,
people think you're mean?
- Well, you know, like
he's not a happy soul.
He's this like amazing teddy
bear of a dad and a husband,
and he really cries
over any and everything,
but in the sweetest way.
- Come on now!
- He was like, no, wait!
- In the sweetest way!
He's very sentimental
about things and you know--
- I don't cry over everything.
- Yeah.
- I mean, just like commercials.
Like commercials get me.
- Commercials get me!
You have a heart!
- Oh my God!
- God! When they get together,
a long lost love on it.
Yeah, they want you cry!
- Oh yes!
- Or any of those commercials
with all the animals that are dying
and seeing those
(indistinct) is killing you.
- Those are terrible.
- Yeah.
I cry too.
I think that your
heartless if you don't cry.
Aint nothing wrong with that.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I feel like the older we
get, we get more emotional too.
I feel like that.
- I feel like that for sure.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- Yes! (laughs) We got an amen.
So what do you think, Bobby,
like the biggest misconception
that people have about you?
- That I'm a bad boy.
- Yeah.
- That the bad boy image
is taken from off stage.
When I'm on stage, I'm a bad boy,
but when I'm off stage,
you know, I'm just Bobby.
You know?
- Yeah.
[Audience] Aww!
- I love y'all today.
(audience applauding)
I mean, maybe I'm not one of
pop culture in that sense.
I don't like read everything or whatever,
but I've never, and I've
been a fan since I was a kid,
so I've never gotten that from you.
Like as a fan, like I've always known
that you're just a talented dude.
And like, I've never ever
gotten that vibe from you.
- Thank you.
- 'Cause most people that are
projecting that image on stage
and like doing stuff, they're
like fun as hell after show.
And you're hanging with
them and they're fun.
And then it's like part of what we do
is kind of you put a show on for people.
- Yes.
- So yeah, I never got that.
I might've missed on that.
- Well, thank you.
I'm glad you didn't get it.
- No. Yeah.
Okay. So there's a
moment in the documentary
where Bobby goes to the graves
of Whitney and his daughter.
So why was that important
for you to put in this?
- Because I hadn't been there before.
- Oh, really?
- No, I hadn't. I don't like grave sites.
So I hadn't been to my
mother's, my father's,
or anybody else's, my grandmother's.
So I just decided that, you
know, I gotta grow up here
and just go ahead and go
by and leave some flowers,
and make my peace with,
you know, with them both.
- I love that.
I mean, I guess when you
were talking about that,
I was like, I don't really
visit things like that too.
I think that's not for everyone.
My sister and I always have this talk too.
Like funerals are hard for everyone,
but like some of us are, even
if you don't know the person,
like I will be there, I'm such an empath.
I take on all that loss
and I become like a
distraction at a funeral.
Like 'cause I'm just
like sobbing. It's weird!
And my sister and I are the same way.
And I can't handle like grave
sites. It's just too much.
'Cause I don't wanna
focus so much on the loss,
I'd rather focus on the
life that we've lived,
and like the good times.
- We agree.
- Like I don't think that that's
necessarily a healthy move
for everyone, you know,
to be able to do that.
But I think that that closure is nice.
- That closure is beautiful.
- 'Cause it's a lot of loss.
And that's a lot on a heart.
- Yes it is.
- Yeah.
Well, you've now reunited
with New Edition for a tour.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So how is that going?
- We...
- [Alicia] Look at that photo.
- [Kelly] This is amazing!
- We actually just finished the tour.
We did 30-city tour
and it was everything
that I expected it to be.
- Oh my God!
- It was a lot of hard
work, a lot of dancing,
a lot of laughing, a lot of joking around.
Just the camaraderie between all six of us
is just so much fun.
It was like camp.
It was like--
- And isn't it different
'cause you're all like older now?
So that's like the thing I love.
Like when I run into people,
like even I've been in
the industry 20 years,
and I run into someone,
I'm like, oh my God,
when I knew you, I was just
such a different human.
I feel like, you know what I'm saying?
Like you grow, and like the conversation,
you have kids, you have like all that,
you know, life happens.
That's gotta be cool.
- It was cool. It was cool
that all of us have married
and we have kids and grandchildren.
You know, some of us
have grandchildren now,
and it's like, you know,
it's beautiful, you know.
To get all the families
together and all of us together,
and you know, just love upon each other.
- And you're like making so
many people happy on that stage.
So, Alicia, like what are you grateful for
at this point in your life?
- Oh, we're just grateful
to be healthy at this point.
We know how many people
have gone through so many health scares
and lost so many people over the pandemic.
We're just grateful to have
each other and our health,
and our children are healthy, you know.
And
today is just better than yesterday.
- Yeah.
- Oh, and that's the goal!
(audience clapping)
That's the goal.
That's a great, I'm gonna steal that.
I'm like letting that sink in right now.
I'm like, yes, that's
the goal, to have it,
and also better for our children.
Well, it's very nice to have y'all here.
- Thank you for having us.
- Thank you so much.
- We appreciate it so much.
- You can see "Biography:
Bobby Brown" starting May 30th,
and "Bobby Brown: Every
Little Step", May 31st.
Both on A&E.